im letzten jahr habe ich versucht mit
fand in die wilden wasser zu kommen das
ist halt nicht ganz funktioniert aber im
endeffekt sei es sich trotzdem in der
businessklasse deswegen schauen wir uns
heute den business class platz ein
bisschen genauer an und gucken lohnt
sich das für wen lohnt sich das und was
bekommen wir eigentlich alles für das
geld also für 0 euro
ach ja und bevor es weitergeht vergesse
ich den kanal zu abonnieren wenn ihr
mich supporten volt und kleinster
folgenden videos verpassen wollt ich
will dieses jahr noch 500.000 abonnenten
knacken und ich freue mich wenn ihr mich
dabei unterstützt weil das hat
tatsächlich funktioniert und ich habe
jetzt ziemlich wenig zeit aber wenn es
irgendwie möglich ist probiert gerade
noch in die lounge zu kommen und erst
meinen und befund zu bekommen
im
mittelpaar schnaps krempelt ergebnis
deutlich weniger gut aus als ich mir
erhofft habt aber nichtsdestotrotz hat
sie mir aber ich muss schon sagen ich
habe mir ein bisschen mehr erhofft ich
glaube hier fliegen aber halt so viele
leute gehobenen klassen dass man einfach
unmenschlich viel platz braucht und das
vielleicht so das was ich mir eigentlich
von einer kleinen lounge erhofft hatte
so ein bisschen verloren wird es wirkt
er wie so eine cafeteria oder so in der
es halt auch champagner gibt nichts
desto trotz der menge platz gute
sitzmöglichkeiten steckdosen kostenlose
verpflegung auch wenn die nicht ob bar
und angebote wie massagen
reinigungsservice und einzelzimmer sowie
man dazu hätte buchen können etwas
enttäuscht von der lounge ging es dann
voller vorfreude ist ein flugzeug direkt
wie den vorteil keine langen schlangen
sondern quasi direkt durch so schön und
gut aber was wäre passiert wenn ich kein
gewonnen werden oder aus irgendeinem
grund im flug nicht wahrnehmen können es
wäre kein problem gewesen ich habe eine
reiseversicherung beim lieblings
versicherungsmanager frage clark ist ein
komplett kostenloser
versicherungsmanager den euch dabei
hilft genau die richtige versicherung
für euch zu finden ihr könnt alle eure
bestehenden posieren eintragen und so
genauen überblick verhalten wo und wie
ihr versichert sagt wie man das
optimieren kann für den bedarf decken
raus wo wir einfach eintragen können wir
eure momentanen situationen ihr seid
umgezogen ihr habt neues auto gekauft
was auch immer da ist eigentlich genau
sagen wo es was zu optimieren darüber
hinaus hat plan experten die euch in
einzelfällen weiterhelfen können und
genau die richtige versicherung voller
passion für euch bin clark ist nicht nur
kostenlos sondern es gibt auch eine
möglichkeit wie ihr bis zu 45 euro in
amazon gutschein von clark bekommen
könnte indem wir den coach page 45
benutzt und rein bestehende
versicherungen hochladen ihr müsst also
nicht mal neue versicherung abschließen
ladet euch einfach die app über den
ersten link in der video beschreibung
herunterladen drei bestehende
versicherung unter 45 benutzten und ich
bedanke mich vielmals das klappt
mittlerweile zum dritten mal unterstützt
und solche videos mit viel spaß bei der
mit dem
interview das der übrigen lag beim
reinkommen war ich sehr beeindruckt weil
deutlich mehr platz war als ich habe
anfang gedacht hätte also nicht wie
befürchtet connolly platz mit besserem
essen und ließen dem platz sondern
wirklich quasi ein eigener bereich
außerdem diesen vorteil die business
class war sie überhaupt nicht ausgebuht
also mit mir saßen drei andere leute in
der business class sonst wäre das
wahrscheinlich auch gar nichts zu stande
gekommen und nachdem ich mein gepäck
verstaut hatte ging die business class
experience die hände
komplett
als erstes kam der chef von der crew zu
mir und hat sich persönlich bei mir
vorgestellt ebenso wie der pilot
und direkt wieder eine situation das ist
mir wirklich unangenehm war wenigstens
passend angezogen aber es ist einfach
komplett oft für mich ist fühlt sich
wirklich falsch an
nach dem start ging es direkt weiter ich
konnte an getränken alles aussuchen was
man sich vorstellen kann also wirklich
alles und mir wurde eine speisekarte in
die hand gedrückt bei der ich mein essen
für den flug ausfällt
es werde ein kontinentales frühstück
haben mit verschiedenen
bio gut in das elektroauto funktionen
hast rief ich werde hier wahrscheinlich
besser erstmal als ich in den letzten
anderthalb monaten zu hause gegessen
habe
eigentlich damals
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen
sollten wir sollten komplett verrückt
ist übersteigen alles was ich jemals
erlebt hat zum frühstück guter kaffee
warme brötchen
champagner nicht irgendein champagner
sondern
ich habe
[Musik]
das erste mal in meinem leben dass ich
mal getrunken habe und das war besser
als gedacht locker luftig im abgang war
klar ich habe gutes essen erwartet aber
das essen war so gut dass obst war so
frisch und die brötchen so waren das
selbst rausgeschossen hätte wenn ich
nicht in ein flugzeug setzen will
und soviel kann ich noch mal sagen das
frühstück waren nicht mal die beste
mahlzeit auf diese bevor ich ehrlich die
nächste mahlzeit aber zeige würde ich
mich als aller erstes mal ein bisschen
ausdenke
ich habe gerade schlafsachen gebracht
bekommen sind das komplett in diverse
einstellungen genau so wie man es haben
will einstellbaren damit war sich
komplette zwei metern flüchten sehen
wenn wir auch eine decke und bezug und
genau das haben wir hier und dazu gehört
eben so dieses kopfkissen damit man sich
ganz entspannt über die sechs stunden
die dieser flug dauert hier hinlegen
kann bedrücken dafür einfach als aller
erstes mal diesen knopf das geht auch
hier über das tablet oder hier über den
kleinen controller und dann ist man
ready sich hin zu nehmen und damit gute
nacht mit noise cancelling kopfhörern
die ist natürlich auf jeden passagier
gab habe ich mich dann in ein
vollwertiges bett gelegt und für ein
paar stunden geschlafen nur um dann von
der stewardess mit einem drei-gänge-menü
geweckt zu werden
[Musik]
herzog ich meins 100 prozent ernst es
war komplett crazy also wirklich
komplett crazies war sowie des brenners
in baden-baden der service war
unglaublich also legt unglaublich denkt
na ja und was soll ich sagen abseits von
unglaublich gutem service war das essen
einfach richtig gut zur vorspeise gab es
ein paar tipps warme fidel und frischen
salat im hauptgang kartoffelpüree mit
viele und bonn und eine schokotart zum
nachtisch
ich glaube nicht dass es essen wirklich
frisch gekocht wurde das wird vermutlich
nur in der first class geben aber
solange man das nicht schmeckt macht das
auch quasi keinen unterschied und man
hat es nicht geschminkt das zeigt
einfach liebe zum kochen ja ja und ich
konnte man so oft nachbestellen wie man
wollte es gar quasi eine champagner
flatrate das habe ich mir nicht zweimal
sagen lassen
habe jetzt auf diesem flug ausgiebig
getestet
jetzt aber zu meinem platz
man hat wirklich vor dem festplatz so
viel platz dass man die ganzen zwei
meter liegefläche heißt wenn man nicht
wegen willen kann man den sitz in
jegliche zwischen position einstellen an
der seite gibt es eine und ausfahrbare
wende irgendwelche armlehnen und man
kann sich diesen sieg so hinbauen wie
man es gerne möchte der sitz ist
wirklich unheimlich bequemen und ich
hatte das gefühl dass die business class
kabine in ein bisschen besser
abgedichtet ist man weniger von dem
fluggeräusche mitbekommt es kann aber
auch sein dass es nur 1 übermäßigen
champagner konsum oder ein placebo lang
auf so einem langen flug wenn man aber
nicht nur gut sitzen sondern auch gut
unterhalten werden es gab leider keinen
kostenlosen internetzugang weil es mir
gewünscht hätte dafür aber eine menge
auswahl an filmen und sogar live werden
das komplette infotainment systemen
konnte man live und mini controller oder
über ein ipad steuern auf dem anschalten
auch parallel hätte spielen können
während vor den live fernsehen läuft
völlig verrückt was mich aber am meisten
gewundert hat war das sind vor allem
hdmi-port gab so dass man den laptop
oder sogar spielekonsolen vorne an den
bildschirm hätte anschließen können denn
es gibt auch eine vollwertige steckdosen
die ausstattung ist einfach wirklich
richtig gut man hat noch einen großen
tisch damit man vernünftig sein drei
gänge menü essen kann eine minibar die
ich gar nicht gebohrt dabei die kurse
aufmerksam war dass ich immer wieder zu
trinken und zu essen hatte und alles in
einem rassigen menge spaß gemacht aber
wie bewerte ich dass
das zimmer in diesem fall der sitzt neun
von zehn alles perfekt außer dass die
einstellungsmöglichkeiten vom sitz
manchmal nicht so ganz funktioniert habe
ich mir das vorgestellt habe und sich
das ding automatische hochgefahren hat
service müssen wir nicht drumherumreden
mit 10 14 absoluter traum verpflegung
habe ich schon lang und breit darüber
gesprochen gibt es nicht mehr zu zu
sagen absolute 10 15 sauberkeit ich
konnte natürlich meine frau lampe dort
nicht auspacken das wäre mir ein
bisschen zu unangenehm gewesen ich hab
so ein bisschen staub und so gesucht
nicht erfüllt das war neun von zehn
sagen lage vermutlich der größte vorteil
an einem liegenden hotelzimmer kann
überall sein und man tritt dazu also
entspannter travel von egal wo und egal
wo zehn von zehn und als allerletztes
der preis ich werde natürlich nicht
meinen preis in betracht ziehen sondern
was der sitz eigentlich kostet irgendwo
im raum gebaut
1800 euro
ich meine für wen ist so ein platz
eigentlich gedacht für businessreisende
oder sehr schlaue leute die wissen wie
sie travel hätten können und mit meilen
wie kostenlos an diesen sitz kommt
kleiner wink mit dem zaunpfahl für eines
der nächsten videos 1800 euro ist es das
aber für mich natürlich nicht mehr 15
betracht darauf wer eigentlich sollte
jetzt keine fünf von zehn eigentlich
zwei von zehn das ist ein ziel von sehen
nichtsdestotrotz war es eine super
erfahrung es hat eine menge spaß gemacht
und das hat mich wirklich beeindruckt
wie gut das alles funktioniert und wie
gut durchdachte das gesamte ding ist ich
würde mich freuen wenn ich den kanal
abonniert das video liegt dann sehen wir
uns in einem was gutes
[Musik]